to do a Western first of all it's an
amazing opportunity but you do a
question and it's on imax then your life
that's the dream you've got characters
that are larger than life you got
landscapes as far as in life the only
way to really experience that is to put
the audience in an immersive experience
and surround them with a screen that's
rich and vibrant
we're gonna film the movie that's going
to be presented that way you gotta
understand your lenses understand your
landscape big backing days with John
Ford made movies you know those big
scope shots of the beautiful landscapes
that represents freedom that represents
the west of western frontier when you
can see that in imax you take the sound
design the horses we've gone to the west
wind and you put that in front of an
audience that allows you to really feel
that space to really feel like you're
part of that world when you have the
opportunity to present your film and
imax present a western and imax it makes
me as a filmmaker feel like a kid again
it makes me feel the wonderment and the
possibilities of what cinema could do
people want to be able something people
want to go and have a real experience
people walk away saying I was fun I want
to do it again that was about
either fall in love you can be scared
but it has to be something that moves
you I think that that's part of what
imax format has always done